Brett is with us in Pensacola
hi Brad how are you good thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up or psychological problem
than a financial problem growing up we
didn't have a whole lot and I have saved
as much as I can and I'm at a point in
my life where you know I think I'm okay
but mentally I don't feel like I'm okay
you know
I guess most people who invest never
really feel like they've got enough so
that's kind of my problem
mm-hmm okay how much do you have in your
nest egg well if you add up all my
investments about 2.5 now about ten
point five million no no - 25 okay all
right good good for you and you started
with nothing you said right you grew up
with well I got out of the military and
85 and I nickels to rub together yeah so
how old are you 56 well and what do you
make a year of these days well it always
varies between 250 and 350 okay and what
would be an example of something that
you think a normal person with two and a
half million dollars as if that's normal
normal person spend money on that you'd
that you psychologically don't feel like
you can well you know it's funny I mean
I talk to a lot of people and I've
searched at many a website and then I
came across your show which I just
learned of that long ago and you know
you always want verification I guess is
it enough you know some people think you
know 10,000 a month is enough 15,000 a
month 20,000 a month to live comfortably
you know just you just don't know so I'm
quite frugal probably driving my wife
crazy calculating our finances every
twice a month at least so what is it a
luxury item you guys have bought in the
last five years what's the biggest
luxury item I got a Porsche in my garage
well okay
hundred grand a little more than that
cool what's the biggest thing she's
bought her rings oh she's got a car at
Range Rover okay so you got a couple
nice cars okay you have any trouble
spending money on cars no that's one
weakness I do that that's not a weakness
you're you you're in good enough shape
to drive both those cars and I would
drive those cars if I were in your shoes
I think that's fine so here's the thing
that I have figured out as far as
enjoying money there's um and someone
from what you're asking me is how can I
enjoy this how do I know them because I
can't enjoy it if I don't think it's
enough correct but if I heard you right
that's what I was hearing and that
happens a lot to those of us that
started from nothing in my case I
started from nothing became a
millionaire and then went bankrupt
before I was 28 and had to start again
because I'm stupid so so I you know I
kind of have that figure in the back of
my head you know that my black clouds
psychologically hovering on the backpack
they're like oh god this is good and you
know if you don't think I do you ought
to ask my wife she's got a bigger one
you know I don't know if we could afford
that or not and I'm like darling we can
definitely afford that it's just but so
the thing that's helped me do that is I
have learned that I can allow myself to
enjoy money easier if I'm doing two
things one is my generosity is high if
I'm giving then it's okay for me to
drive a Porsche you know that helps me
enjoy in the Porsche more I think if I
was stopped up and I wasn't ever giving
anything not helping anybody with any of
the money then it would be harder to
enjoy the force okay and so like I Drive
out really really I've got several
really nice cars I'm a car geek and so
I've got ridiculous money in cars but as
a percentage of my net worth which is
the second thing and as a percentage of
my giving even though they're really
ridiculously nice cars like you have you
know you've got wonderful cars but you
know
in your case you've got let's say 170
thousand dollars for the cars under
fifty thousand others where the cars
sitting there and if if you give away
three thousand dollars a year then
that's going to make it hard for you to
enjoy those cars then so generosity
factored in ratio to what you're
enjoying whatever it is if you travel
and you're gonna spend a hundred grand
on travel and you only give two thousand
dollars away a year it's gonna be harder
to enjoy the travel because you're
becoming a hedonist
you're becoming inward-facing and
selfish and greedy kind of a person even
though you didn't mean to but generosity
helps break that down in your spirit and
keeps your soul a little cleaner the
second thing I look at is I look at
ratios and now that's what I'm doing
with your cars a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars with the cars as a
percentage of two and a half million is
nothing if you took those like keep the
Porsche in the garage I usually I Drive
a ranger yeah but if you took all your
cars and put them in the front yard with
no insurance and set fire to them your
life really doesn't change your life
doesn't change it's a small enough
percentage of your world that it's easy
to enjoy because you're not out of line
but you take a guy who's making $60,000
a year and has a negative net worth with
student loans and he drives a fifty
thousand dollar car you know and those
guys are all over America right and see
that makes it that not only makes that
car stupid but it makes it harder to
enjoy because the ratios are out of
whack he's got too much of his life tied
up in luxury things if a girl's got a
ring on her hand and that is the entire
couple's net worth it's harder to enjoy
that ring where Sharon is like she's got
this ridiculously wonderful ring looks
like a headlight but when we got married
it was a we got married I mean she got
it to a point two three it wasn't even a
full fourth of a carat that one's in the
safe because it's nostalgic but you know
it wouldn't even show up around the ring
that she's got
I'm bragging I'm just saying it's
because we've worked so hard you and me
both for so many years if my generosity
is up there I find I can enjoy a portion
of my wealth and if it's a small portion
of my wealth small enough then I can
enjoy it we can go on a luxurious trip
that costs more than we used to make in
a year
back in the day you know and you could
do that right now and you could you know
you could too and it's it's it's well
it's a high percentage of your emotional
memory it's not a high percentage of
your current world and that allows you
to enjoy it so hold on I'm gonna send
you a copy of the only book I've written
on this subject well all my other books
are on money the book I wrote on
Wealth's called the legacy journey and
I'll warn you ahead of time that's a
Christian book because it's the only way
you can view wealth and keep it in
balance and so it's the only book I've
written that's exclusively Christian and
if you're not Christian you really won't
enjoy it so throw it away or use it for
a culture on your table or something but
I think you'll get something out of a
hold on I'll send me a copy of it